hi I'm Donna Nowitzki and I teach global
entrepreneurial marketing at Stanford
University I am a Fenwick and West
entrepreneurship educator and I also am
the CEO of a startup called gift II this
is my depending on how you count it
either my third or my 19th startup I've
been very active with startup companies
since about 1985 when I joined Sun
Microsystems as a product manager and
then did a start-up in the 90s called
clarify and was VP of Marketing there
and then joined venture capital business
where I was VP of Marketing and 16
different startup companies and now and
then left that to do another startup
called big tent which was a b2c company
and now my most recent startup called
lifty which is all about micro gifts on
the social media
I'm passionate about two things I'm pad
about marketing because I love the
process of understanding customers and
understanding technology and try to
figure out how to communicate the
benefits of technology to real-world
customers so to me that's just really
fun I'm also passionate about
entrepreneurship because I love the idea
of solving whether it's one of the
world's biggest problems
or whether it's a micro gift that helps
a neighbor say thank you for something
another neighbor did in a new social
media kind of way it's exciting and fun
and makes a difference in the world
one of the huge trends in marketing is
that people think of marketing as a very
soft science touchy-feely and these days
it is not at all marketing is very
quantifiable and very measurable and you
should be out there really understanding
what tactics you're deploying and why
and what kind of results you're getting
from them so as someone that has always
liked math it gives me a chance to mix
my math background with my interested in
mark interest in marketing and customers
I would definitely be the entrepreneur
side so I have some technical background
but I'm not a computer computer
scientist that's going to go invent the
next really cool widget however I love
to recognize that's a really cool widget
we can build the company around that and
put together using my marketing skills
and business skills put together the
rest of the package that it takes to
make an innovation you know live to its
fullest potential